unfortunately we have some bad news
about the upcoming apple silicon 27-inch
imacs and because of these three new
pieces of information that just came out
today some of you guys are going to stop
waiting for this imac and you'll end up
buying something else like a macbook
instead and with that info there are two
key things that you have to keep in mind
as far as pricing and release dates so
let's jump into it it has been over a
month since vadim did his last video on
these new imacs where he dived super
deep into all the technicalities it's a
video that is so detailed that nobody
else can even match so you guys should
still go and check out that video but
today we have new info that changes up a
few things the first one is that we
officially have news that production has
started on these new imacs and as we
expected them to be coming out in the
springtime possibly march that looks
like it's all lined up because these are
already being made now that is just the
first piece of information that is the
positive one
where it gets worse is that we have news
of multiple
colors of these imacs coming out now why
is that bad news colors are good right
well when we look at the other imac the
24 inch that also had leaks of multiple
colors you guys saw that not only do we
have a bunch of colors to choose from
but that also meant that it had white
bezels paired to all of those colors and
a lot of people absolutely hated that
because it no longer looks like a clean
sleek mac you have this white bezel all
around instead of a black one people say
it is distracting especially if you like
working in darker environments it just
doesn't look like your clean
professional imac and this is what so
many people were waiting on the 27 inch
larger model for a nice clean imac with
the performance of apple silicon that
looks great standing on your desk not
like a consumer product that's meant
just to look nice in your kitchen or
somewhere else and because of this that
also means that this computer the entry
level models are going to be focused on
those regular consumers meaning that the
chip that comes with it is probably
gonna be lower power than we thought
before the ports might be limited uh and
other things which leads us to the
second piece of news that came out today
and that is the fact that this machine
is not going to ship with a mini led
display that has support for pro motion
so not the pro display that we expected
that also comes with these 14 and 16
inch macbook pros now to me when i heard
the news and all the leaks coming out it
didn't make a lot of sense because these
imacs that you typically start at about
1800 bucks and go up and how in the
world would apple give it such a great
display for that price point along with
the other news that came out and that is
that there are three new displays
standalone displays that apple is going
to be offering which mark german and
felipe talked about earlier this year
and dylan dkt has actually seen shells
of them that are unbranded so this is a
24 inch display a 27 inch display and a
32 inch display now people have wanted a
consumer display from apple for a while
now since it's been i don't know six
seven years uh since they've actually
been making one and even though lg
partnered with them in 2016 the
ultrafine 5k which i've owned for years
i still have it it is not at the same
level and if that one sold for 1300
bucks we know that apple will not sell
their version which is also supposed to
have promotion and mini led for 300
bucks it's probably going to be 1500
maybe 1800
and then the pro display xdr which will
be updated to better mini led and
promotion as well for 5000 plus that
stand that is another thousand dollars
so this makes sense apple's base imac 27
inch is gonna have an lcd display
slightly updated but it will not be a
mini led now this report was from digi
times which has a great track record but
the original person that talked about
mini led coming out was ross young and
he's actually the only person that
talked about it coming out for the
macbooks with promotion and he got that
completely correct and guess what he
actually just replied and said that he
still believes that they are going to be
coming with many led displays for this
inch apple silicon imac so who is wrong
and who is right in this scenario well
personally i think both of them i think
that unfortunately the base model is
going to come with an lcd display
multiple colors and it's going to be
limited at that lower price point it's
gonna be for consumers white bezels but
now i do think that they are still gonna
make an imac pro version a version for
those of us that want extra performance
better ports 10 gigabit ethernet that
want black bezels and maybe a space gray
design just like the previous imac pro
and have that killer 27 inch mini led
display with promotion built in if you
guys know apple the lg ultra and 5k that
the same panel as the imac so if they're
going to be making an external display
say for maybe 1800 or even up to 2 grand
with that display standalone it just
makes sense to offer it in an imac as
well it's just going to be thicker with
the all-in-one built-in design but what
that tells us now is that
this machine is gonna be a lot more
expensive and if you're waiting for one
with black bezels without the multiple
colors with this display you're gonna
have to spend a lot more money than you
thought you would have to
previously now it absolutely makes sense
for them to make one that is like this
because if we look at the previous
release of the m1 macbook air and
macbook pro that was way more powerful
than the intel version and the same
thing with the 14 and the 16-inch
macbooks they just destroyed the intel
versions so how in the world is apple
supposed to make just this entry-level
colorful one that has an m1 pro possibly
m1 max built into it because as you guys
know from our previous video
the m1 max chip the cpu actually gets
beat out by the 2020 intel imac and the
graphics card that's in the imac isn't
that much slower than the very best m1
max along with that it is limited to 64
gigs whereas the imac you could support
up to 128 gigs and the graphics card had
16 gigs of its own memory so it doesn't
make sense for apple to just make this
entry level model and then have a
machine that's apple silicon that's a
huge release for them the first redesign
being slower and less capable in many
ways than the intel version and that's
where we get into the 20 core chips that
minchi quo leaked earlier in the year
and vadim talked about in great detail
and we also have info about code in mac
os having multiple um basically support
that's unused for a do a duo chip two
emerald axes together we have the
hardware strip that can connect them
that we just found from a photo that was
released of the actual chip not what
apple showed up on stage all of these
leaks and all of the software and
hardware adds up to these high-end m1
duo chip that will actually give us the
same jump of performance compared to the
2020 intel imac as we got with m1
macbook air and pro and also the m1 pro
and max ships with these new macbooks so
all of that does make sense the main
question is will this imac pro higher
end version be coming out at the same
time as the lower end colorful ones that
are going to be probably limited in
ports and have the white bezels with the
lcd display or are they going to be
pushing that back to maybe summertime or
even the fall time just basically
sitting there and waiting or having to
say hey that's going to be at least 3
000
if that mini led version is going to
have an m1 pro allowed or up to four or
even 5000 like the original imac pro if
they force you to get an m1 duo chip
with a high amount of ram and storage
space in order to get the sleek look
with the black bezels
and that mini led screen built in so you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below is this going
to change your mind on waiting for the
system if the lower end more affordable
ones maybe up to 3 000 or even more come
with an lcd display and white bezels
with multiple colors
you guys let me know your thoughts i
want to hear about them definitely go
check out vadim's video right over there
has so much awesome details if you guys
want to know more most of that still
applies click that circle above to
subscribe to help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers this has been max
and i will see you in the next video
[Music]